hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Saturday but it doesn't
matter how great your Saturday has been
so far after you see this game is gonna
be like at least twice that good it's a
game from round seven of the 2018 Isle
of Man chess tournament and it's really
like Tom meets Najma Dean of game really
a wonderful masterpiece and well without
further ado I'm sure you're all just
going to enjoy it so let's just dive
straight into it it's between program
Honda and dravot Asia so a grandmaster
against an international master from
India Prague who opens the game with
efore we have a c6 the caro-kann defense
d4 d5 and now II five the advanced
variation of the caro-kann and here
Bishop to f5 there are some players who
will voluntarily lose a tempo and play
see five here which is a very sneaky
Botvinnik system how to play this
against this advanced variation of white
and it's very uncomfortable for white
even though black seemingly voluntarily
loses a temple very very sneaky move so
after a 5x5 and here we have h4 at the
tall variation of the advanced caro-kann
also possible here is the immediate the
g4 which is the bayonet attack so if
you're facing a lot of car cons then you
might want to you know put this into
your repertoire but the problem goes for
h4 fir first now g4 is definitely a big
threat so you have to stop a leader by
playing h6 but Ravi goes for h5
immediately
we have c4 e6 and not Knight to c3
simply developing pieces we have Knight
to e7 and now comes a knight - g - e -
preparing to bring this Knight over to
g3 to harass the bishop on f5 d captures
on c4 we have nice to g3 attacking the
bishop on f5 and also opening up an
attack against this pawn bishop back to
g6 and now comes Bishop to g5 pinning
the knight and e7 so black is it's not
all that easy to develop pieces for
black so you do have to try something
Queen to b6 simply developing a queen
tonight at least seven his next perhaps
even castling queenside but also this
comes up with an attack against the b2
bond probably is Bishop captures on c4
and here black has to make a choice does
he want to continue with Knight to d7 or
does he want to stay true to his plan
has he displayed Queen to b6 on the
previous move so does he capture the
pawn and is the pawn perhaps poisoned
well ravi decided to capture at queen ki
after son b2 and now your knight is
under attack and c3 you can either
defend it with sorry but that seems that
this is a bit high up with rook to see
one or as Prager played in the game
night see to e4 we have Knight to f5 now
as you don't want to allow something
like nice to be six well this night is
still here now Knight you don't you can
capture but then the other night is
coming to e4 so doesn't really make much
sense nice to if I was playing out the
bishop is covering the d6 square and
here Prabhu can definitely play Knight
captures on a5 Bishop captures and but
then after look to be one Queen can come
to a3 and the black defense this Bishop
can come to before with check it's a
it's a it's an okay position to play for
black so Praga doesn't waste time he
simply castles and here we have Knight
captures and g3 Praga does not recapture
automatically but rather and in between
move a nice assertion to rook to be one
now your queen is under attack
so okay you first have to ask ourselves
can I grab the two rooks and perhaps
play the game this way not really
I can play Queen captures Queen captures
and captures on f1 white will not of
course recapture simply Queen captures
on b7 and you are getting checkmated
here there are so many threats here
Queen to c8 being one of them so after
we play something like f6 make some room
for your King also block the bishop
not even a queen captures rook but
rather Queen to see a to check king 37
and now he captures pawn captures and
now after Bishop captures on f6 King to
f7 Queen captures an e6 will be
checkmate so a very nice idea so you
don't have any options for doing
something like this so Queen to a3
getting in the Queen out of the way and
now F captures an g3 opening
this file for the rook well so it's a
semi-open file now we have Bishop
captures on e4 and now what do you play
here of course you can play row capture
77 White will have a very nice attack
but Prague doesn't waste time instead of
this row capture some b7
he goes for the immediate captures on f7
and what's the idea behind row captures
on f7 if King captures rook then can you
find the the idea behind this rook
sacrifice even feel free to pause the
video and try to solve this hypothetical
situation
I'll give you a couple of seconds food
to decide whether you want to do it so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
Queen Trapper and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
the move is rook to b3r up to b3 which
the idea that if now Queen captures an
a2 then rock after Sun b7 is check and
then Bishop simply picks up the Queen
and it's all over if you don't pick up
the A to point if you go here it doesn't
really matter
we're up to capture Sun b7 check and the
Queen captures Queen is next and the
only square that doesn't lose you the
queen is going to 8/5 but still it's no
better rook captures on b7 check King
has to move and now after Bishop
captures on e6 you're getting checkmated
you can never go to a 7 because of Queen
to h5 and the bishop to f7 is too big of
a threat
for example Queen to a6 whatever you
play doesn't really matter Bishop to
have 7 check King to h7 and now as we've
said Queen to h5 will be checkmate or
you can try going down the board with
the King after this Bishop to f7 check
but it will still leave the checkmate
so after rook captures an f7 first Queen
captures on g3 here Ravi also is now
threatening checkmate on g2 Prager
simply brings the room back rook to f2
and now your b7 point is still under
attack we have b5 and here Bishop is
under attack if you move the bishop it's
it's an okay move but still it loses you
time for example Bishop to e2 Queen to
a3 the Queen escapes and now I have to
rope to b3 you can go quint way for you
pin the rook and black may be still able
to defend this game
so after b5 we have Queen to you one
again a very nice move by Prabhu the
threat is rook captures on f8 and the
queen of course is unguarded and g3 so
you could easily lose the Queen here
Bishop to f5 closing DF file for the
rook so now rook captures on f8 is not a
possibility but here probables Bishop
captures on e6 and now again Bishop
captures he'll would lead the rook
captures rook captures and Queen
captures and g3
again you would lose your queen here so
after Bishop captures any six Queen
captures on f2 you have to give a part
with your queen here if you don't if you
try anything else like we said if you
capture the bishop you're gonna lose
playing something like g6 you get to
this very nice Bishop to f7 check again
you cannot capture if you capture then
again rook captures on f5 captors and
between capture son g3 and after Bishop
to f7 if you go King to d7 then rook the
b3 again will trap the Queen Queen to a
queen to g4 rook to a 4 ended the Queen
has nowhere to go
so here after Bishop here captures on e6
Ravi decided to part with the Queen
Queen captures we have Queen captures
and now Bishop captures on e6 so black
still has some compensation for the
Queen material-wise but all of his
pieces are still undeveloped so if he
can get his pieces out perhaps he can
still pose problems for prabhu but here
progress progress in no reversing fear
mode he pushes d5 there is no time to
waste
he wants to open up the C file we have
seek after some d5 and now an excellent
move Queen to c2 pressuring the c6
square so you can't develop this knife
because of this check also Queen to c7
is coming with some nasty ideas and also
Queen to g6 is a possibility if black
isn't careful and tries to for example
guarded the c6 square in a different way
then Queen to g6 is checkmate in one so
after this Queen to c2 move Bishop to e7
is played freeing the f8 square for the
Queen for the King and also trying to
develop but now comes the Bishop
captures
King captures and Queen to c7 check and
here perhaps was black celeste a good
attempt to with a nice to d7 to defend F
26 check King to f7 rook to f1 check
Knight to f6 would still allow black the
hole did this game somewhat but most
likely white would win it he captures G
captures you still still have two rooks
and the bishop against a Queen and the
rook but white is still much better here
with the wide open black king
so after Queen to c7 check Bishop to d7
was played but now again Prague is in no
reverse gear mode e six he wants to open
up the file either by king capturing for
example King captures then immediately
you get rook to e1 check King f7 Queen
to f4 check King moves and now this will
lead to the checkmate after King to f7
you can block for one move for example
here but why I can simply ignore you and
after here you can go Queen to f5 and
now Bishop has nowhere to go
whatever you play simply captures and
captures will lead to the checkmate
after each six I Rowley decided to play
rook to c8 he attacked the Queen and now
comes Queen - b7
now the bishop is attacked and also the
rockin a8 you cannot move the knight if
you move the knight so the rooks protect
each other then the knight is no longer
guarding the bishop here King capture
son e6 was played now comes Queen
captures on e8 and now Knight to c6
so perhaps but can still create some
sort of a castle but it's very unlikely
Queen to b7 we have before now
protecting the pawn with the night and
now comes Queen to a6 and here rook
captures Sun before is a threat and
there are a lot of threats Queen to e2
check picking up the h5 pawn so if white
simply starts picking off pawns
he will be much better and there's
really no way to prevent this if you
move the King either d6 or EE 6:37 white
will simply pick up the other pawn and
then we'll create passed pawns of his
own and easily win this game so King to
d6 was played a rope capture some before
as planned and now rook the da perhaps
trying to move the King and the double
ship and then start pushing his own
passport but rook to be one we have d4
and not looked the c1 with a lot of
pressure against this knight King to c7
was played and now F
Queen capture Sunday 7 rabbit Asia
decided arrived resigned the game and
moved 32 so a brilliant brilliant
victory for Prague nonde and really
really making your Saturday more
enjoyable than it was I hope what if you
resign well everything is falling apart
now if you move the King back for
example King to d6 then you get Queen to
c5 check and now of course if you move
back you're gonna lose this pawn once
you lose this pawn there's no counter
play for black tonight is of course
pinned and if you try something else
instead of going to c7 if you go King to
e6 or something
then Queen captures on h5 you will lose
all of the pawns and again there's
really not not much you can do and of
course if you don't go here if you go
here then Queen captures before
immediately and black again has no
counter play so yeah after Queen
captures on a7 of course the Queen
cannot be captured as the knight is
pinned we already mentioned that it's a
really really an amazing game so I do
hope you enjoyed it and that your
Saturday was improved I would like to
thank Kevin Wright and Paula Bertie Leah
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it and we
do have the standings after round seven
so here are the standings it's from
matches comm article I will put a link
to it in the description below you can
check out the entire article there's a
lot of a lot of nice analysis to all of
the games from round seven not all but
some of the better ones and a lot of
nice photos and everything so feel free
to check it out
Maxine was Cheryl I grew up in first
place with five and a half and seven
players are in top with five and a half
Maxine were sherrilyn Grove Nakamura
Hikaru rather slow voice chick Wong how
are cutting Irish Michael Adams Hume
Jeffrey and then with five points we
have a couple of super grandmasters left
11 Arjen onigiri with Jonathan Anand
Alexander Grigio Sergey Carrick in the
tournament Alex a sheriff and military
million called pearl pearl egress and
then with four and a half points it's
Lima Kramnik Wesley saw Richard reporter
with it Gujarati and Vladislav artemyev
so those were the standings I do hope
you enjoyed that as well as usual you
can check
my previous videos you're thankful for
watching and I'll see you soon
feel free to suggest any of your
favorite games from this tournament and
if nothing else interesting arises we're
gonna continue with the Spassky Fischer
series thank you all and I'll see you
soon